hey everyone it's sarah register nurse
rn.com and in this video i'm going to
demonstrate how to measure an infant's
length
to measure length what you want to do is
you want to lay the baby on a surface
that you can mark you'll need a pen for
this
and you may need someone's help to help
you
measure the baby because you're going to
measure from head to heel
so lay the baby back you'll want to put
their head midline
like this and then just mark their head
then you want to take the leg and extend
it
outward like this make sure it's nice
and extended
may have to work with them a little bit
and then mark it at the heel
and a normal length in an infant is
about 18 to 22 inches
and then we're going to gently lift the
baby up
so we're going to measure this and we're
actually measuring this in inches
and the infant is 22 inches
you can also use another method of
measuring length by using a medical
device called a stadiometer
okay so that wraps up this demonstration
on how to measure an infant's length and
be sure to check out the other videos
in this series